[موسيقى]
عندما دخلت الى عالم الدبلوماسيه في عام
1978 كان انذاك عهد اريجان الذي تحبه كذلك
ماركتش
وكان عهد دخومين ايضا وصول الى ايران كان
لمنبر يتعلق بدنشو بينك في الصين الذي كان
لديه برنامج اصلاحات وبعد اربعين عاما
نرانا وصلنا الى نهايه دائره العالم يعيد
تنظيمه نفسه واعتقد اننا اليوم في مرحله
هي نفس ليس نفسها بدات في الحرب البارده
عرفت نهايه الشيوعيه كان هناك الكثير من
المراحل مثل الربيع العربي والازمه
الماليه فالعالم يشكل نفسه من جديد
[موسيقى]
اعتقد ان سمت الكثير من العناصر عنصر
الرجال هو احد العناصر ولكن كما قلت
العالم تغير بشكل كبير نعيش في عالم بعد
الحرب العالميه الثانيه اسس على قواعد
دوليه مع وجود الامم المتحده التي انضمت
اليها غالبيه الدول لكن الجهات الفاعله
تغيرت وهناك ايضا ما اسميها تحول
الاجيال وجيل اليوم ليرى العالم من منظور
مختلف اما كان عليه لما يوجد اليوم بلدان
لم تكن موجوده على الساحه في السنوات
الستين او سبعين الماضيه هناك دول حازت
استقلالها وهذه مساله مهمه هناك بلدان
ناشعه افكر في بلدان الكبرى مثل الصين
والهند وهناك ايضا عوده لتركيا
[موسيقى]